like any other area in the United States
the State of Florida has a healthy share
of urban legends and local myths take
for example the legendary Swampy the
Region's Bigfoot equivalent a hulking
creature said to run amok in the state's
many swamps in aquatic areas identified
by its strong repugnant odor and deep
guttural throat calls or the ghosts of
the Saint Augustine Lighthouse a Grizzly
tale revolving around two young girls
who drowned in the nearby sea while
their mother was working the lighthouse
too distracted to hear the cries of her
children as they were swallowed by the
current and returned to the brine it's
rumored that on Some Nights the twins
laughter and cries are heard from the
top of the lighthouse not scary enough
what about the Devil's Chair a seemingly
ordinary bench located in the town of
Cassadaga that was supposedly built by
the Devil Himself every night at
midnight the man in red returns to his
back and if you sit beside him he'll
whisper Wicked horrible things into your
ear leaving you forever scarred and
haunted by The Experience just don't
leave a drink behind when you run off
the bench in Terror though another
Legend says that any unopened bottles
left on the bench will mysteriously be
opened and drained by the morning
torturing damn souls for eternity makes
you a thirsty guy we guess but to a
seasoned viewer of SCP explained urban
legends and local Oddities might seem a
bit mundane in comparison to the strange
inexplicable anomalies that the SCP
Foundation regularly researches and
contains after all the truth is almost
always Stranger Than Fiction and if an
actual anomaly gets picked up as an
urban legend the SCP Foundation is going
to do everything in their power to shut
it down cover it up and make the story a
little more digestible for the general
public that means relying on the same
tired tropes and cliches we've all heard
before cursed dolls bigfoot-like
creatures ghost hitchhikers we all know
them and as fun as they are the most
popular stories aren't always the most
unique or interesting and if you peer
deeper underneath the surface you can
always find kernels of Truth in the most
common place of Legends for example
what's commonly referred to as Bigfoot
or Sasquatch is actually
scp-1000 a super intelligent prehistoric
race of ape creatures known as The
Children of the Night who were
slaughtered by early humans and forced
to hide from the world in order to
preserve their species a cursed object
or location the foundation deals with
those all the time and stories of ghosts
are as commonplace in the anomalous
world as they are in the ordinary one
but what about an anomaly that utilizes
urban legends to further its own
nefarious goals one that's lifeblood is
localized to a single area
today on SCP explained we're going to be
talking about
scp-3640 an anomaly that capitalizes on
the interest and Intrigue those urban
legends generate specifically those in
the State of Florida we already talked
about the variety of weird and creepy
stories the state calls its own but what
else is Florida known for tourism
retirement communities beautiful summer
weather slightly crazy individuals
making news headlines for ridiculous
reasons how about Disney that's right
the State of Florida is known for Walt
Disney World the granddaddy of all theme
parks that brings in millions of tourist
dollars annually and the hub for some of
the most iconic characters and stories
in the world if you've ever been to
Disney World then you know about the
costume characters that roam the park
silent mascot costume Renditions of your
favorite TV and movie characters posing
for pictures and having fun with
children the park is practically
infested with
they seem inescapable it's pretty
understandable that some people are
unsettled by mascots they can sometimes
be downright creepy with those unmoving
expressions giant heads unnatural
movements and the faces of familiar
fictional characters in the right
context a mascot can be just as scary as
any horror movie monster or urban legend
could ever be here's a situation for you
you've just landed at a Florida airport
you're ready to go to Disney World and
enjoy a vacation after you've been
worked to exhaustion as a junior
researcher at the SCP Foundation you
want to get familiar with the state but
you're trying to cut down on your phone
usage after all you're on vacation why
not do things the old-fashioned way and
unplug from Electronics you spot a
brochure rack in the distance perfect a
paper hub for everything touristy in the
area among the hundreds of jet skiing
courses Beach information and mini golf
pamphlets one brochure in part
particular stands out to you maybe it's
your background in the anomalous but you
just can't help yourself from picking up
a booklet on Florida's urban legends
knowing what's behind the curtain
working for the SCP Foundation really
makes these types of things more amusing
you've seen how the sausage was made and
it's a lot more terrifying than anything
known to the general public heck you
know for a fact that the organization
you work for has more than likely not
covered up most of the actual incidents
that inspired these local Legends
nonetheless you pick up the brochure
interested in the self-guided tour of
Florida's paranormal hot spots and
you're impressed to find that this
booklet has it all everything from skunk
Apes to a cursed doll it's all in here
you chuckle and Tuck the pamphlet
underneath your arm but little do you
know you're about to experience
something more horrifying than any urban
legend could ever be you see if you paid
attention to your foundation briefings
before you left the state of Florida you
would know that any foundation Personnel
who encountered tourist brochure
pamphlet's advertising self-guided
paranormal tours in Florida are to bring
said pamphlets to the foundation's
attention immediately mobile task force
Lambda 12 nicknamed Pest Control is
primed on demand for incidents related
to these brochures why because they're a
part of a phenomenon categorized by the
SCP Foundation as
scp-3640 but what is
scp-3640 why is something as innocuous
and fun as a paranormal travel brochure
an object of high interest for the SCP
Foundation well you someone who should
have maybe listened to the regional
briefing conference back at site 19
before you left on your vacation are
about to find out after perusing your
booklet and ruminating over the numerous
locations at your disposal you decide to
visit one after you get settled into
your hotel after all you're about to
experience a week of family-friendly fun
at the house of mouse why not partake in
a little [ __ ] just to get the blood
pumping a bit of living life on the edge
before the scariest thing you have to
deal with is a 10 bottle of water and a
three hour waiting line to ride that
giant golf ball you drive all the way
out to the location the pamphlet
specified a bridge by the name of
Sunshine Skyway located right outside of
Tampa Bay visiting the bridge at night
might also get you a visit from a
mysterious and beautiful hitchhiker
woman who stands on the side of the
bridge and attempts to flag down cars if
you happen to take her in she'll begin
to weep growing progressively louder and
louder in her screaming and crying until
you reach the other side of the bridge
and when the driver turns back to ask
her what's wrong the woman will have
vanished Without a Trace sounds like a
fun time right maybe you can find her
heck maybe she's single and interested
in an enthusiastic and kind Junior
researcher of the SCP Foundation you
would never contain her you promise
having to raise your voice over the
sound of her weeping and crying in the
back seat of your car or maybe not this
vacation time outside of the lab is
making you think some strange strange
stuff whatever the case is you want to
see a ghost girl so you make your way
over to the Sunshine Skyway at 11 at
night just like the pamphlet specified
the bridge is strangely empty especially
for what's usually a crowded stretch of
the road in fact now that you realize it
there's no one else here just you your
car the black night sky and the sound of
your humming engine well up the road you
go looking for this supposed ghost
hitchhiker the Skyway is quite the drive
and the longer you ride the less safe
you feel but you're fine right it's a
very popular Bridge driven by thousands
of people every day and night it just so
happens to be completely empty at an
ordinary time of night and you can see
the dark outline of a figure in the
distance standing in the middle of the
road as you dry five closer and closer
you start to make out the figure a bit
more a circular head a tall wide body
and two more circles on top of that
round ball head closer a little closer
and wait is that there's absolutely no
way that's who you think it is is that a
Mickey Mouse costume standing in the
middle of the road it apparently is and
it seems like it's not getting out of
the way you honk your horn but the
overground rat doesn't listen it's still
standing there unmoving you slow down
you know what Disney's legal team is
capable of and you are absolutely not
going to jail for running over Mickey
Mouse so if he's not moving out of the
way you will instead you try to maneuver
around the stationary mascot but
suddenly out of nowhere the thing leaps
15 feet into the air and jumps onto your
hood you scream as the Mickey mascot
skitters across the roof of your car
clawing and tearing at the sunroof
trying to get in you push your foot on
the gas as hard as you can enough forced
pound Mickey from the roof but it's not
enough the mascot hits the ground but
immediately gets back up and starts
running after your car almost
instantaneously it catches up to your
car again and uses its strength to pry
off the door on the driver's side of the
car exposing you and causing you to lose
control of your vehicle you swerve
crashing into the side of the bridge and
banging your head off of the steering
wheel you never thought your life would
result in death by Mickey Mouse but the
rapidly approaching costume creature
seems to be saying otherwise the Mickey
creature bends down and uses both of its
gloved hands to grab you from your car
seat with enough Force to break the seat
belt and give you minor Whiplash from
being flung into the air so quickly this
is it you know it's over and you don't
even know what's going on or why this is
happening you're just another victim of
something you don't understand like the
countless dead you spent your life
researching or so you think just when
you assume that it's all over a shot
rings out from a the bridge and you see
a salvo of bullets pepper Mickey Mouse's
back carefully missing you with
impressively accurate Precision Mickey
drops you banging your head on the
concrete and runs towards where the
bullets are coming from several armored
heavily armed soldiers appear from the
side of the bridge and circle the mouse
they fire again but it has little effect
on the mascot once again he lunges
forward knocking a soldier off his feet
the mascot dashes off into the distance
leaving over the side of the bridge
though no splash is heard in the water
below you don't see the mascot Landing
or even escaping it's like he was never
there in the first place but at least
it's gone now and you have these unknown
soldiers to thank you for your weight is
that an SCP Foundation logo oh no their
Foundation task force operatives before
you're able to fully regain your senses
you can already hear the task force
Captain telling his underling to prep
you for amnestics in an interview the
soldier approaches you and you're
thankfully able to muster out a few
Choice words namely wait wait wait I'm
with you guys I'm a junior researcher
the captain pauses and laughs to himself
what are the odds after you're processed
and taken to the nearest facility where
your identity as a card-caring member of
the SCP Foundation is confirmed you're
letting on what exactly it was you just
saw back there as it turns out you had
an encounter with
scp-3640 an anomaly centering around a
set of travel brochures that advertise
self-guided tours of all of Florida's
paranormal hot spots if someone reads
the brochure and goes to a location at a
set time just like you did they'll be
preyed upon by a mysterious predatory
entity or set of entities that resembles
costumed mascot characters owned by the
Walt Disney Company Mickey Donald Goofy
the task force Captain explains that
they're all there and they're all over
the State of Florida hundreds of mascots
may be more they're fast dangerous and
the foundation knows remarkably little
about them including how they grow
reproduce or even consume their prey all
the known hotspot it's advertising the
pamphlet are routinely watched by
members of The Pest Control mobile task
force where operatives are authorized to
neutralize
scp-3640 entities with lethal Force
which is how that task force was able to
thankfully show up at the right moment
and save your life
scp-3640 only attack those who read the
brochures and haven't been seen being
hostile or hunting outside of the areas
specified by the pamphlet after you
recollect yourself and thank them the
captain hands you a file briefing on
scp-3640 gives you a Stern warning and
tells you to familiarize yourself with
it before you leave the facility what a
way to start your vacation you think
just when you thought you were able to
escape the daily horrors of working for
the foundation you stumble upon an
anomaly yourself but you undoubtedly
have more questions about
scp-3640 after all anyone would after
witnessing as weird and strange and
anomaly as that in the wild you ask the
captain why the foundation hasn't
captured an scp-3640 insta
especially if they're so common in the
Florida area he sits down Sighs and
explains the foundation did try a while
back it was a standard d-class test held
in the St John's river the location of a
supposed river monster the d-class
Personnel was dropped off at the
riverbank and told to follow the
instructions in the pamphlet if they
spotted a mascot they were to shoot at
it with a tranquilizer gun after
dredging through the river for a few
minutes and being distracted by a neat
looking alligator the d-class eventually
came head to head with none other than
Donald Duck himself who emerged from the
river and immediately began moving
towards the d-class the d-class
naturally freaked out completely and ran
away from the scene but Donald was
simply too fast just when he thought he
was safe the Donald mascot emerged from
the shadows and knocked the camera and
radio off of the d-class's head there
were sounds of a struggle but the
d-class never established contact again
however his subdermal tracking
transmitters continue to operate and
before they went offline completely they
luckily detected the location of the
d-class's body it was just outside of
the Epcot amusement park engaged by the
captain's story you ask him what
happened next surely the foundation
launched an assault on Epcot to figure
out what happened to the d-class right
the captain Grunts and tells you that
the rest is classified but you're not
satisfied you're refusing to move until
you figure out what happened to this
d-class the captain rolls his eyes and
perhaps feeling sorry for you decides to
tell you the rest of the story him and
his team were deployed just outside of
the Epcot Theme Park right next to a
one-story concrete Hut where the
d-class's location was tracked they were
equipped with heavy arms a net launcher
and a flamethrower all perfect weapons
for subduing these deadly mascots while
Lambda 12 was typically used to hunting
anomalous bugs and pests they figured
that hunting down Donald Duck and Minnie
Mouse was more or less the same thing
when you squint really hard and pretend
that they have
the task force broke into the hunt
revealing it to be a maintenance shed
with a mysterious trap door in the
middle of the floor underneath a ladder
led to a tunnel system similar to the
ones built underneath the Disney parks
that the employees used to get around
from park to park the team spotted
several dressing rooms and storage rooms
all empty and devoid of life after some
exploration the team followed a low
rumbling noise to a closed door they
slowly opened it revealing an abandoned
Boiler Room with a white mascot costume
at the foot of the boiler curled up
around an unknown object an operative
approach the costume and poked it with a
rifle identifying it as an empty Daisy
Duck costume the team examined it
further and found a human arm bone
inside the suit disgusting to be sure
but nothing the task force hadn't seen
before they turned over the suit to
examine the object it was curled around
discovering it to be a purple plastic
egg with an embryo inside scattered
across the floor were more eggshells the
squad gathered them as well as the bones
of the d-class in the costume to bring
it back to the facility suddenly the
task force heard noises in the distance
and assumed an attack formation they
noticed the floor of the entrance they
came in was now covered in dark fluid
and polyester stuffing the trail of
liquid exactly matched their path of
infiltration into the tunnel after
determining the situation to be safe the
squad carefully left the tunnel the way
they came bringing the costume and the
egg with them after several weeks the
egg hatched into a miniature stuffed
Donald Duck toy the foundation dissected
it discovering it to contain a plastic
endoskeleton and a rudimentary polyester
stuffing muscular system inside and that
was everything the captain had to say
there was never any other leads on the
scp-3640 anomaly just strangeness and
inexplicable inability to capture or
understand the mascots you think the
captain for not only saving you but
explaining what was going on you before
you left the facility to go back to your
regular foundationless vacation you took
another glance at the document the
captain handed to you on the back page
was a chilling letter dated from 1979
written to Florida Governor Reuben Askew
by the Walt Disney Company it read as
follows the Walt Disney Company thanks
you for your cooperation in this matter
regarding the unlicensed Walt Disney
character operators please pass along
the following information collected by
the outstanding men and women of the
city of Orlando's Police Department to
the Florida National Guard if a
character is spotted call to get its
attention and then rapidly flash your
flashlights at the costume if it does
not flinch fire on site aim at the head
if possible L same at the knees to
disable them and then finish them off
with headshots body shots have been
shown to lack Effectiveness deceased
characters are to be incinerated no
other means of disposal are advised we
are currently pursuing alternative legal
mean of shutting down these unlicensed
operators and hope to achieve a
settlement within the end of the year
cordially yours the Walt Disney Company
now go watch
scp-2805 Disney on Ice and scp-823
Carnival of Horrors for more anomalous
theme park Madness from SCP explained